des proches uni pour célébrer avant tout
un homme de famille my boss a marqué
bien des gens et pas seulement grâce à
ses prouesses sportives
si la famille a souhaité vivre son deuil
loin des caméras et l'a reçu de nombreux
témoignages de condoléances environ 800
personnes sont venues rendre un dernier
hommage au défunt depuis hier matin
j'étais un petit peu d'un nuage bleu
pâle et alger comme un keita décédé mais
a côtoyé de long des jauges comme on
voit pluie là ça nous permet de mettre
un peu de punch sur naples est
le premier ministre du québec a tenu à
rendre hommage à l'ancien joueur un gars
tellement drôle tellement sympathique
tellement simple un être humain
exceptionnel le drapeau du québec été
mis en berne à l'assemblée nationale
françois legault s'est aussi dit ouvert
est ce que mike bossy se commémorer ce
que ça sera à laval parce que
avant d'avoir brûlé
le livre des records la ligue nationale
il ya fait la même chose dans le junior
majeur à laval donc on regarde ceux
actuellement sur la route encore je vais
retourner cet accord braintree qui a
chanté lors de la cérémonie à la demande
des filles de son ancien coéquipier
j'ai chanté avec tout mon coeur en
mémoire de notre dernière rencontre qui
a été heureuse a dit trottier avant
d'ajouter que son coeur a sourit de
nouveau aujourd'hui malgré la douleur
cette et grandiose a comme sujet à
l'image de mike bossy un hommage sobre
pour un joueur exceptionnel et si
antoine hey hey radio canada montréal